if I put 20 seconds on the clock can you
give me a rundown of what that first
film was about I mean no pressure right
go
uh man you know searching for meaning
travels across the Galaxy to find this
planet not only is he able to find
himself he's also able to find love and
he has to help this planet fight against
these Invaders that are trying to take
over the world
that was good 18 seconds
that's actually the quickest City ones
ever one time seconds there you go
and go movie about opening your eyes
man why are you so good that was darn
good five seconds
no fear
he's a wounded Marine he's in a
wheelchair is sent to uh Pandora to him
it's a hostile place where he can't
breathe the air and all that and he
starts working for you know Colonel
quarrich against these people and it
becomes a spy but also falls in love
with beautiful and amazing naturi so it
it just morphs into this beautiful love
story
[Music]
well the original Avatar is about a hard
ass and yet lovable Colonel whose job is
as head of security in an inherently
insecure environment he does it to the
best of his ability he uh in the end is
foiled but he goes down swinging
he goes down with two big arrows to his
chest but he's a like I say a very very
tough guy and so he regroups in hell and
he is back again to to to carry out the
mission but I think I would say that for
korish
um nothing is Forgiven or for God yes so
um it definitely continues but I think
it's so solidly about this family that
they've created
so what does her heartbeat sound like
[Music]
Mighty when you're building this kind of
a franchise you have to build it around
the world first that's what the first
one was about building the world it's
almost nostalgic it's been long enough
that we're coming back we're feeling
that world again but this one is about
the family the technology is Advanced so
it's such a a more Rich environment so
we're really excited about this and I
need you to be strong
foreign
it's an amazing opportunity that you
know Jim's given us all and um you know
and this is his gift he loves making
movies and you know now it's time to
share with the world
[Music]